if you're looking to scratch that action
RPG itch it sounds like John Smedley
next game might be what you're looking
for smedley formerly of Sony Online
Entertainment is heading up a new
company called pixel mage games the
studio's first game is a 2d pixel art
action RPG called hero song pixel mage
has already raised 1 million dollars
through private investors and it's
hoping to raise another 800,000 through
Kickstarter in order to finish its game
smedley is put together a team of
veterans to help develop the game
including EverQuest co-creator and lead
designer built Ross and best-selling
author Patrick Rothfuss who wrote the
name of the wind and the Wise Man's Fear
smedley said in a statement our goal
with pixel mage games is to make
extremely deep in hardcore games in a
beautiful pixel art style with an
incredibly deep multiplayer experience
we're calling on the community to be
part of the project as we create a
unique game that we're sure fantasy RPG
fans will enjoy additionally hero song
will allow people to control their own
servers hundreds of people can play at
one time pixel mage said hero song is
scheduled to release in October 2016 for
more information on the action RPG head
over to the game's Kickstarter page